hello everyone and welcome to another
truly awesome game from round six of the
fiji grand prix currently being played
in belgrade it's the final round of the
elimination uh not eliminations is the
final round of the preliminaries then we
go into elimination rounds with the
semi-finals and finals uh it's the mithy
andreikin versus atm back row and i know
you guys are very excited uh due to the
position from the thumbnail yes it is
going to be a very exciting game
but
what's special about this game is that
usually when you have one player winning
a game and the other one losing uh
there's a one player is very happy and
of course the other player is sad
but what's special about this game is
that it made one player very happy and
two players very sad so we're going to
explain what this means but only after
we check out the game
so uh the undraking with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have d5 knight
to f3 e6 c4 and d captures on c6 so the
result horizontal variation of the
accepted queen's gambit uh with e3 going
after the c4 pawn and now knight to f6
bishop captures on c4 and c5 now
challenging the center here and now we
shift to the classical defense uh
castles uh and now a6 preparing to
further expand on the queen side would
be five and so on with knight b to d2
uh
uh sorry knight b to d2 and now uh c
captures on d4 first we have e knight
captures on the e4 and now bishop to c5
so still waiting with this b5 idea could
be a little bit dangerous there's always
uh tricks like queen to f3 and then
black will
run into some developing issues uh and
now knight uh four uh to b3 and this
here is a new move so already as of mu 9
we have a completely new game but just
to show you uh for example if b3 which
isn't on move we can just um play it
like this then uh you don't really lose
a pawn here even though it looks like
you are for example bishop captures e
captures queen captures uh after bishop
a3 that black king will not have a very
good time in the center of the board
it's uh going to be all white for the
rest of the game so instead we have
knight four to b3 uh attacking the
bishop now and it is uh at the end to
move uh this is now a completely new
game so basher back to a7 and bishop
back to e2 you know that b5 is coming
this will force the bishop to move right
away and you want to bring your knight
to c4s that b6 square is looking very
very good for the knight so here b5 with
a for now challenging the setup b
captures on a4 rook captures on a4 and
now black castles the safety we have
knight to c4
and bishop to d7 first not going for the
queen trade just yet first challenging
the rook here rook back to a1 and only
now knight to c6 we have knight b to d2
and now the knight is being shifted to
f3 not a a great square for the knight
on b3 we have knights to d5 and knight
to f3 we have knight c to b4 uh a lot of
horsing around here and bishop to d2 now
uh queen to b8 uh now preparing to bring
the rook into the game also just adding
more the uh defense to this uh b for
knight and now knight c to e5 we have
bishop to b5 as the bishop here is
attacked you do not want to
allow this knight to get to d7 so first
bishop to d5 we offer a trade of bishops
bishop captures on b5 queen captures on
b5 and now knight to d4 chasing the
queen back queen to b7 and now queen to
b3 sync if the knight moves of course we
will just capture the queen here so
queen to c7 uh getting the queen out of
the way with an attack on the knight
here and now knight d back to f3
guarding the knight on e5 we have rook f
to b8 and now black's works are very
nicely developed and rook f to c1
attacking the black queen on c7 queen to
d6 and now comes e4 challenging the
knight here and this is where the fun
really starts so what do you play here
your knight is attacked your bishop here
from d2 guards all of these squares so
you can't go anywhere on this side of
the board you have to go back you can go
knight b6 you can go knight to f6 knight
to f6 seems like a perfectly nice idea
however here knight the c6 was played
now opening up a discovery on white's
queen and uh what do you play now well
again uh there are a couple of moves you
can play here for example you could just
go for a for this trade rook captures
here you attack the black queen black
captures white queen white captures
black's queen for example bishop
captures on d6 we're gonna capture on d5
we're gonna capture on e5 and after
knight captures an e5 rook captures on
b2 now as the bishop is singing we're
gonna defend it knight f3 captures here
and now you would have a bishop and the
knight against the rook but the black
would be up two pawns so i would be sort
of a sort of a trade-off white should
always be a little bit better here
but nothing nothing too serious however
after knight to c6 and why this game is
so enjoyable
uh andreikin doesn't go for a rook
captures on c6 rather he plays queen
captures on b8 uh he offers a full queen
uh and not a full queen he offers the
queen
for some a very nice counter play now
what can what can be played here
obviously you could capture the queen
with the knight you could capture the
queen with the rook and you could
capture the queen with the queen and
only capturing with the knight is uh
even playable for black which makes it
all the more interesting if if
just to give you an example if rook
captures on b8 we still can capture on
c6 this is hanging this is also hanging
we're going to capture this as well and
once the queen moves for example he
captures on d5 queen captures and now
rook the c7 not saying okay our bishop
is attacked if the bishop moves then the
f7 point is really weak so we're going
to defend the rook e8 now rook captures
on a6 this rook is coming to a7 then
there will be uh just uh you know the
insane pressure on the seventh rank so
rook captures on b8 uh not really uh all
that impressive so uh after queen
captures nba we could play queen
captures on b8 but this is uh uh pretty
similar but now we capture with the
knight as there's a nice fork in coming
queen captures on v2 let's say e
captures on d5 now we're still
threatening to pick up the bishop and
after bishop to c5 we can play d
captures on e6 and it's a very very sad
position for black let's say if captures
on e6 rotate the b1 chasing the queen
away queen a3
uh again not much for
uh for for black to look for here it's
just uh uh well uh
a rook and two knights for a queen not
not a lot of fun even with the the
outside pass pawn it's not going to be
playable for black so instead after this
queen captures on v8 obviously only the
knight can capture and this is what the
tn plays he plays knight captures on b8
and now rook the c8 with check we have
bishop to f8 and now only now e captures
on d5 and now what we get here for
giving up the queen
is that you it's not all that easy to
develop the queen side the bishop here
is stuck as you can't move the king is
still on g8 and you always have to worry
about stuff like knight d3 bishop to b4
going uh sorry about that arrow uh going
after that queen and the bishop and then
the f8 square just gets annihilated uh
so can black even hold this well
uh the question is yes but you have to
play queen captures on d5 uh here uh the
end plays e captures on the e5 and now
black is completely busted however he is
very lucky here as andreikin does not
find it he plays rook the c1 uh instead
of the immediately winning rook to e1
point is that uh as we said the knight
can't really be played as rook on e8 is
hanging so your idea is to play knight
to d3 with tempo
to threaten bishop to b4 and then this
rook is coming to e8 so it's a very very
tricky and
there's not much you can do here just to
give you an example if rook to a7 we
just continue with knight to d3 this is
the threat and now what do you play if
knight to d7 to keep an eye on the
bishop here still bishop to b4 attacks
the queen and let's say queen b6 now we
play rook e38 and there's no way you
hold all of this everything is nicely
defended there are no
threats along the back rank um so there
there's really nothing to do here if you
play g6 to try and get away there's even
ideas like night and night after e5 uh
just everything is getting destroyed
here then if the knight moves then just
bishop captures here and the game is
over or rook captures also works
everything works here and on the other
thing
after rook to e1 if you don't play
something like this you could play f6
let's say you just want to get rid of
the knight or something like that let's
say knight to d3 and now a5 let's say
okay you stop bishop to b4 still just
rookie to e8 and that's it there's no
playing this position
so uh that was in the position however
andreikin missed it he played rook a to
c1 he had some different ideas but now
f6 uh
seems like seems like a pretty good
option and now you don't really have
anything with knight to d3 because you
can't combine it with the idea of rook
from e1 coming to e8 so here we have
knight to c6 uh sorry knight to c6
attacking the knight here if the knight
moves then the rook will be captured uh
however this is the best idea we should
just capture the knight here and after
the rook is captured on a8 now we play
queen to d7 and the game nicely
continues uh
with uh well with good play for for both
sides however here after knight to c6 we
have a5 by black not going for stopping
this bishop to b4 idea but now it's much
much easier for white to play this here
rook to d8 attacking the queen queen to
c7 now and now knight f to d4 so really
mounting the pressure and how can how
can black do something here uh well
again knight captures on c6 is the best
option queen to b7 was played in the
game but knight captures is again best
because after the rook is captured now
it seems like you can't do anything you
can't capture here because the queen
would hang you can't really do all that
much but after queen to b7 now the rook
and the knight and d4 are hanging and
here white wouldn't really have anything
better than to capture on f8 king
captures rook captures on c6 and after
queen captures on b2 yes it's still
three pieces for the queen
but at least you have a past eight pawn
to keep it interesting uh so uh
uh
black would have a actually a very good
game here so instead after knight uh
f2d4 queen to b7 not going for this very
nice knight trade and now knight
captures uh
uh on a5 attacking the queen so what's
uh the idea well uh the idea is that
we've grabbed that pawn it's a very
dangerous pass spawn and it's which
temple black has to move the queen queen
captures on b2 now knight d to b3 uh and
here king to f7 now uh with knight d to
b3 we block the queen's
coverage of the b4 square so bishop to
b4 is coming and there are not a lot of
ways for black to tackle this so king to
f7 now the bishop can move but still
bishop to f for now now we go after the
queen side
bishop to b4 uh and now we have rook to
c7 with check
again uh you could go for something like
rook captures on b8 it seems like you're
winning uh however this would actually
be losing because after rook captures
bishop captures and bishop captures an
a5 you cannot recapture as if you're
recaptured then this is checkmate so
that's not gonna end well for you so
after bishop to b4 instead we have rook
to c7 check if we can double rooks on
the seventh or on the eighth should be
very good for us king to g6 uh back will
very nicely hide his king here and now
rook the g8 going after rook captures on
g7 but not just bishop captures on a5
there's always king f5 and there's uh
not all that much white can do here so
knight captures on a5 and now comes rook
captures on a5 and this is where things
start to go incredibly wrong for atn uh
there's no reason to capture this knight
that there are many other moves that
black can play here
uh this
rook captures knight is not a losing
move for black but it really makes life
super difficult for black so here rook
captures an a5 was played and now
there is one move that can really make a
lot of problems for black feel free to
pause the video and try to find the move
that keeps the game going for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
black king hasn't got all that many
squares this is covered this is covered
here this is covered also by the bishop
so the only squares that the black king
can use are these two squares and how
can we fix that and also uh get rid of
our back rank issues uh that is of
course by playing pawn to g4 this takes
care of these two squares and also gives
us gives our king the g2 square uh if he
ever needs it and he will need it so
congratulations to everyone who found
the the g4 pawn move uh it's um
still playable for black but you have to
be incredibly precise uh and here you
have to play f5 you just have to give
your king some squares uh uh otherwise
uh it's not gonna end well for you but
here it would seem that etienne uh
saw something that simply wasn't there
he played knight to d7
and
okay uh it seems like uh he he thought
he maybe had a mating attack and he most
certainly doesn't
but that's just how chess works here
underakin captures the knight rook
captures on d7 and now comes the mating
attack still the position can be saved
with f5 uh and this will ensure uh
athena draw with perfectly but here
after queen to b1 check the position is
now lost
so of course uh
you can't play
all that much you can block with the
bishop which is silly and you can play
king to g2 so of course king to g2 now
comes queen to e for check and of course
okay you can't go anywhere on the back
ring because of rook to a1 however you
can play king to g3 but now comes rook
the a3 with check and again what do you
play if you block with the bishop black
will very happily capture that bishop
and win the game but here just king the
h4 living leaving the bishop under
attack uh and he was in fact in this
position on rule 42 that etienne bakr
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is uh
due to the
extremely powerful g for pawn black is
getting checkmated whatever uh black
does uh if we go after the bishop here
we're just gonna capture the pawn here
and after king here rook captures here
king here and the rook the other rook
delivers checkmate uh the only squares
the king could go are f5 and this but
the discovered knight well by the
opponent by the rook but still there
there is absolutely nothing uh for
etienne to do here so after this came to
h4 uh it was uh in this position that uh
etienne bakr resigned the game
so really really uh sad not only for
etienne we said that this made not one
but two people very sad the other one is
sam shankland who was pretty much
already in the semifinals uh as he
needed either
either backroad to win the game or to
hold a draw and this would ensure his
qualification to the semi-final but as
he lost to andreikin now it is andreikin
who is qualifying uh to the
uh to the semi-final and uh andreikin
will face giri uh in the semi-final
tomorrow and rapport still waiting for
his opponent so really really uh an
impressive fight and even though uh when
all of this started happening here for
example
uh let's just move back a few moves
uh here after
this knight to c6 move even though rook
captures on c6 is objectively best for
white you can see how queen captures and
v8 made so much problem uh for black so
much more time was wasted as it's much
much more difficult to calculate and
there were many many opportunities uh
even uh you know just making it uh a
completely winning position already here
if rook to e1 has been played but you
you always have to look for such moves
it's so
uh so impressive that
such a thing is even possible but both
both of them missed it and well chess is
just a very complicated game uh you know
uh
most of the times uh so a really
impressive game at the end uh fought
well but andre king bested him in the
end uh and well what uh what a beautiful
game it was uh so yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any other
uh favorite games of yours from the
uh from round six do share in this
comment section below using hashtag
suggestion i will of course
look into it and if not we're gonna
check out some games uh from the
semi-finals that start tomorrow so yeah
once again hope you guys uh enjoyed it
uh i would like to congrats of uh thank
you uh congrats for the new job
elizabeth
greetings from zravkoboost
zoolongclosebox.com and lucasticaris for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the fide uh grand prix
until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day